her she's got four grammys and an oscar
but rachel
this next project has her teaming up
with the obamas
oh yeah nichelle pretty incredible her
just one of the many artists putting
their musical stamp on this
one-of-a-kind series make a statement
and say
just how exciting was it working on the
show with president
and mrs obama as executive producers
was the pressure on to just like make it
perfection
it was more exciting more than anything
it made me really want to want to you
know
kill it it's like wow you know i'm part
of something with the obamas
is it's kind of like life changing think
of we the people as kind of like a
schoolhouse rock
focused on u.s civic lessons the 10
animated episodes drop sunday
on netflix the president was super
involved he would listen to the songs
and
there were a few times where he was the
one who said well that's not actually
correct and you're like
all right then i think that's the end
the word on that
[Music]
what are you hoping kids especially will
take from this project
i'd like to believe you know my
generation and younger
we are going to set the tone for the
future and um it's up to
us to be informed kids are going to
start being more proactive and not
reactive
and and really take control of our
future
and this project is going to empower
people i mean it empowered me i learned
a lot
her is joined by lin-manuel miranda
janelle monae
bebe rexha rapper kyle and others so
could this turn into a concert series as
long as we have independence to keep our
people protected
and i just say i would love to hit the
road with this
are you kidding me oh my god that'd be
the most lit tour of all time and we'd
be helping the community the entire time
it'd be cool
i'd wake up every morning and give
myself a paddle in the back right yeah
i'm educating the youth
i'll break it down into a classic you
see all i gotta say is can you give me a
heads up when the tickets go on pre-sale
[Music]
okay